excusez moi je vois tir juste le décor
quelques secondes regardez c'est
terrible j'étais déjà gaga mais là ça
devient n'importe quoi en direction en
couple avec lui messieurs dames
aujourd'hui son dû il est incroyable il
s'appelle one single be font disent est
ce ça vous dites là c'est une petite
pépite mettez le dans vos favoris il est
pas si connue et pourtant il est
vraiment incroyable c'est que des photos
et des vidéos de trucs une seconde avant
qu'une catastrophe comme son nom
l'indiqué d'ailleurs son nom est
tellement explicite que ce sera le titre
de la vidéo
aulnoye skis sage et respecté ce que
j'attendais petite mise en bouche
regardez moi ça c'est une photo qui a
été prise d'un pont pile au moment où il
s'est cassé c'est bon pour vous c'est
une oeuvre d'art cette photo d'ailleurs
on aurait dû la mettre dans la vidéo il
ya pas longtemps la sur les oeuvres
d'art elle a plus sa place dans celle ci
qui si clément se plaît fais nous un
petit zoom sur les différents profils la
de gens avec une petite musique
classique qu'on saisisse bien le moment
que chacun passe dans cette image là
une petite vidéo au oui avec un chien il
va bien on encaisse qu'il est arrivé
[Musique]
quoi beck
j'imagine même pas comment le battre a
dû paniquer à temps mais c'est hyper
terrifiant je vais me méfier des
balançoires pendant qu'un char d'assaut
les profs de physique là vous vous
régalez en voyant ça réellement cette
rotation parfaite qui a entraîné le
décollage de sciences et nantes
wait for it ok le gaf 1 gâteau et au
milieu il a mis un pétard mais non mes
mecs c'est tellement dangereux
il fait péter ça à 20 centimètres du
visage des gens c'est tellement
dangereux mais bac tu te souviens pas
quand on avait 8 ans pour les allumer il
compare t à 15 mètres en cours s'est
fait pas ça vraiment ce pas pour rien
qu'il a coupé la vidéo avant qu'ils
aient du gâteau qui volent c'est qu'il
n'y a pas que du gâteau qui a volé ses
enfants sont à deux doigts d'apprendre
beaucoup de nouveaux mots aïe aïe aïe
déranger les anciens qui sont en pleine
activité qui a débuté il ya plusieurs
dizaines de minutes ça entraîne des
situations qui sont dans le top 3 des
pires situations de ta vie cet enfant
n'a plus eu l'occasion de jouer avec un
ballon c'est fini from ronaldo tout
ricard allez hop un stand karma les wait
for it et un stand karma c'est vraiment
une valeur sûre les gars si c'était des
crypto monnaie tout le monde hurlait
dessus je vous le dire il veut le
pousser
[Musique]
oh maman non il a voulu faire le truc de
cm2 la tape sur l'épaule là et après tu
te caches de l'autre côté
fake c'est incroyable ça me dit qu'il en
tombe par terre tellement c'est horrible
comme si tu assures aux mecs white des
white day mec j'ai pas de connaissances
suffisantes en électricité pour savoir
s'il se passe un truc est ce que tu te
prend un vilain coup de juste tu fais ça
ou est-ce que c'est léger une pile 9
volts j'en ai aucune idée
quoi qu'il en soit c'est hyper stressant
quand tu réalises que tu as à la
mauvaise fait moi je sais pas ce qui est
le plus vif que quelqu'un sorte un gun à
une fête où des images de gens qui font
la fête j'ai pas ce qu'est le plus beauf
le guen ne me choque pas tant que ça
finalement à sa gelée vu ces terribles
mec
regardons ce que tu as gagné une femme
paraplégique il va recevoir un cadeau
qu'est ce qui pouvait mal tourner à quel
point la production peu cette foire et
[Musique]
quel malaise [ __ ] mais quel malaise le
malaise équivalent race a cédé fois en
rentrant dans le taxi par réflexe comme
la plupart des chauffeurs c'est des mecs
je rentre je dis bonjour monsieur mais
sans même avoir vu qui conduit et c'est
arrivé trois fois et je suis un des
trois forts où c'était pas un monsieur
c'était un madame est vraiment après
l'ambiance delà de ma course était
dramatique
j'avais carrément peur de croiser le
regard de la conductrice dans le rétro
du milieu là j'étais vraiment comme ça
venait je sors on oublie je commande un
auteur nos taxes et du coup c'est
horrible les gaffes comme ça quand on
mari décide de modifier la voiture
électrique de ton enfant oh mon rêve les
gars c'était tellement de notre rêve
d'avoir sa [ __ ] il a le modèle porsche
quelle chance moi je vais pas faire le
mec de ma résidence ya un mais qu'il
avait une moto à trois roues électriques
et il était trop sympa je me souviens un
jour il a descendu et on faisait la
queue genre juste pour faire un aller
retour dans la cour avec sa moto 3 où
est ben franchement j'avais qui fait ça
n'intéresse que lui de tous ceux qui
regardent la vidéo ça intéresse que ce
mec là mais quelle mauvaise idée de pimp
et à un truc électrique ça accélère déjà
tellement
papa tu adores les voitures et fast and
furious mais lâche toi sur ta voiture à
toit pas celle de ton fils aura tuto
pour apprendre à faire des fouilles au
corps seniors c mais l'écart était si
beau mâle se passe et elle a l'air de
tellement gérer son truc j'ai envie de
manger ce qu'elle est en train de
préparer
qu'est ce que le mal se passer j'adore
les réactions des dards en caux et leur
arrivée dans glee ils font pas cas
j'adore sache hyper satisfaisant à voir
ça te rassure c'est ça démystifier un
peu tes parents ils ont aussi leurs
moments de de fail c'est clairement son
père ou alors je dis ça juste parce que
j'ai la même coupe de cheveux c'est
possible mais profite bien de ta vidéo
devenue virale carla comme pour les
autres tu rejoins picard tu ne jouera
plus jamais avec un ballon mon garçon
legolas airs qu'est ce que c'est encore
vous préoccupe les gars j'espère que
vous nous avez fait honneur dans ce bris
dit le fait explosive
les gars vous avez mangé quoi là un maxi
space cake ou genève va il parle il sort
d'un dessin animé e c'est incroyable non
le tourisme a diminué en france après
cette vie des bons la première leçon a
complètement raté
c'est dur n'est pas confirmé mais tu
abuses frérot tu fais une leçon de
conduite à ton fils à deux mètres d'une
voiture de clients tu l'as cherché tu
l'aimés pas trop ce qu'ils mangent et
l'impression un temps après la vidéo
pour un alibi genre on n'a pas fait
exprès c'est volontaire ça non
non le héros un tour sur elle les gars
la poule c vraiment l'animal le plus
genre claqué en terme de défense ça
court pas très vite ça fait pas très
peur c'est vraiment le truc en bas de la
chaîne alimentaire c'est terrible j'ai
de l'empathie pour cette poule elle se
fait battre par son reflet vous rendez
compte de ça c'est terrible pour cette
photo est pas mal il porte des oeufs et
regarde pas devant lui regarde quelque
chose d'autre son prochain passé sur la
peau de banane
ma question est la suivante est ce que
c'est une légende ou pas que des gens
glisse régulièrement sur des peaux de
banane et tombe du coup est ce qu en
france qu'une personne est déjà tombé ce
qu'elle a marché sur une peau de banane
fin ça me rend fou mais ça va pas ou
quoi la méchant chirac quand même c'est
gratuit
[Musique]
alors là il ya une vraie erreur de
quelques vrais et erreurs de calcul
qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est le même
chien qui a mangé l'oiseau c'est pas
possible que les animaux se fois c'est
le même fait que quand quelqu'un cannage
de mes parents se foire ça me tue de
rire je vous jure je conçois pas qu'il
puisse se foirer comme ça j'idolâtre
autant un chien que mes parents c'est
bizarre mais c'est génial le photographe
d'un mariage est tombé après une photo
pendant sa chute du coup on voit les
gens qui prenaient en photo réagir à sa
chute
ça tue [ __ ] ça donne une photo
tellement original il a fait exprès il
est malin et d'ailleurs son numéro
s'affiche en bas d'écran et sponsorise
cette vidéo let's go si ce n'est qu'en
yann pas le trophée de la meilleure
animation mai mais qui l'ont pas fait
exprès ils n'ont pas fait exprès pas
possible qu'est ce qui s'est passé well
autant de vidéos avec du feu là et c'est
un seul vrai dit entretenue par des
pyromanes ou sait comment là un schéma
est un chat qui joue ensemble
cette vidéo a été conçu pour moi sur
mesure playes
ok à chaque fois il fait chier le chiba
et il part en courant sautant dessus du
truc sauf que le tibet va prendre sa
revanche il va prendre sa revanche
frérot ne sous-estimez jamais un schéma
[Musique]
si mme chiba ici la team félin je veux
pas vous entendre
soyez attentifs à ce qui vous entoure ok
je joue avec un bébé crocodile du
gouffre et au profite bien tu pourras
pas voir si ta vidéo a bien marché j'ai
l'impression et tu en train de gagner
fils de je joue du fils ça c'est au
remake
à l'époque je me souviens quand après je
faisais rien de bizarre sur le pc est
inquiète mon pc il était joueur pile en
face de la porte de ma chambre je
retrouverai la porte le prêtre ou tu vas
y est et l'écran de mon pc c'était même
pas moi et ça avait pour effet de
terriblement me stresse et pourtant je
vous jure je faisais rien de fou mais
c'est tellement oppresseurs et lui en
plus dans le genre oppressant il a un
reflet de vite ça va vont être déçus à
jamais c'est terrible qu'est ce que
c'est que ça avec mon coeur il s'est
arrêté mon kurys et aride et d'ailleurs
en parlant de ça la vidéo il y avait
longtemps avec seb où il y avait un
serpent ils nous ont expliqué les gars
après que en fait un serpent des fois il
est juste genre pas content il n'est pas
d'humeur et du couffo pas le manipuler
et nous il a failli ne pas venir dans la
vidéo le serpent parce qu'il n'était pas
d'humeur et le mec il nous a raconté ça
nous a expliqué que le matin même il
s'est fait battre par le serpent aux
questions puisqu'il n'était pas d'humeur
mais dis le nous un an avant de mettre
toute notre coup il qu'ils fassent des
bisous à 7 dans le coup là c'est dingue
et bien messieurs date europe ce casque
j'espère que ce petit ce maudit de vous
a plu je me suis
égaler on a vu un si bas je suis heureux
lemière m'attends d'ailleurs est
d'ailleurs en parlant de ça j'ai vu que
l'eau de masse qu'il allait adopter un
schéma
bon alors lot de matchs on s'inspire de
meilleur j'ai l'impression prenez soin
de vous on se retrouve très bientôt mais
petit des petits chatons le petit chaton
pour cette fois
[Musique]